foreign
[Music]
you have to be on the right side of the
ball or the left side of the ball now
when you have something like this that's
right for the whole it seems like well
that's an easy shot but you have to make
sure that you have the right
delicious here and then it's got to go
like this all the way down to here
oh so two walls has got a bounce on this
one that one and all right basically
three rails maybe three rails
and that a little like a tap on the
other one
wow that's strong that's strong yeah
yeah so it looks like that's easy but
that's not easy at all that that's like
one of the harder shots to get yourself
well you're in a perfect position to
make the next block how'd you get into
opening Anthony I was in bands with my
brother and uh I would write song
parries about everything that was
happening in the news and the OJ thing
I'd heard of that happened and I wrote a
song tired about it I hope he played it
on his show uh WBAB on Long Island and
people loved it so he goes hey can you
come in and do it live and me and my
brother are like yeah came in did it
live and I thought this was my shot I
just poured everything out I started
doing impressions I was coming on the
news and Opie goes uh dude that was
really good why don't you come in next
week again and it just snowballed from
there we got an offer to go to Boston
and I never looked back I threw my sheep
at all worker tools out on 95 on my way
up to Boston
it's all about knowing like the cue ball
speed and knowing Powerball is gonna
come off the ball when it contacts it at
an angle and it's you get completely
obsessive because it's so hard to
predict and then the more you do it the
more you get like muscle memory and the
more you kind of understand where the
ball is going so you're not even
thinking too much using intuition
there's a lot of thinking
endings are happening at the same time
it's super complicated
it's fascinating
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign